I've heard gossip
it's a dragon queen it's quite beautiful
what does that have to do with anything
John is young and unmarried Daenerys is
young and unmarried you think he wants
to marry her
an alliance makes sense together they'd
be difficult to defeat what's up ladies
and gentlemen welcome back for another
Game of Thrones Season eight prediction
video today I want to talk about
Daenerys and John's relationship now
that they decided to take it one step
further by becoming more Mantic Lee
involved with one another there are a
few different reasons why I think this
can cause problems in the future so I
want to go over these things in this
video I also want to show you what some
of the cast members had to say about
this as well my friend Doug back who is
a patreon supporter of mine sent me a
clip from an interview that was released
right after season 7 ended in this
interview John brain and Tyrion talked
about how this relationship may cause
some problems next season after I saw
the video it kind of reminded me of the
same way season six ended in the season
six finale Jon Snow became king in the
north then there was a look exchanged
between Sansa and Littlefinger and this
caused the community to have endless
debates about what this look actually
meant and I remember a lot of people
were thinking Sansa was going to betray
Jon because they believed Littlefinger
still had influence of her songs oh
there was some tension between Jon and
Sansa at the beginning of season seven
over the decision-making but now we have
a similar situation with new problems
heading into the final season Jon and
Daenerys had sex and we find out jon is
the rightful heir to the Iron Throne
instead of Daenerys and we all remember
the look Tyrion had on his face when he
realized what Jonathan Aerys were doing
in her cabin so what will happen between
John and Danny next season let's see
what Peter Dinklage had to say about
this scene in the season 7 finale it's
dangerous for everybody involved I'm
sure it's good for both of them
in the moment but you don't even get the
relief of how beautiful it could be or
should be it's no it's just it's not
good but it should be but it's not it's
Game of Thrones it's a long history of
romance not ending well on this show
Peter Dinklage is exactly right
romantic relationships do not end very
well in Game of Thrones this is not the
type of show where characters get to
live happily ever after
but does that mean Jon and Danny's
relationship is doomed and next season
the first major problem they will face
is showing up in the north together even
though Jon Snow is king in the north
people are not going to be happy that he
is bringing a Targaryen with him most of
John's bannermen already voiced their
opinion on Jon leaving the north to go
and greet with Daenerys they still
haven't got over the fact that the Mad
King killed several Starks himself and I
can't blame them Sansa was also not very
happy with Jon wanting to go south to
meet Daenerys and now she knows John
bent the knee to her which ultimately
surrenders their crown in the north
Shonda and Littlefinger talked about
this in the season 7 finale never asked
for my opinion why don't you start now I
can't believe he'd surrender the
northern crown without consulting you
this is his writing his signature he
pledged to fight for Daenerys Targaryen
bent the knee
Sansa didn't seem too angry at the time
but she did have other problems to worry
about so it will be very interesting to
see how Sansa and even Arya react to
Daenerys showing up in Winterfell with
her dragons and a foreign army another
problem that could arise is the fact
that Daenerys burnt
samwell tarly father and brother alive
the maesters at the Citadel did not
reveal this information is saying before
he left old town but it's only a matter
of time before he finds out we all know
Sam didn't love his father but I'm sure
he still had love for his brother as far
as I know I don't think Jon even knows
Daenerys burnt the tarly's alive unless
Jon found out off-screen when Daenerys
came back from the battle all she told
Jon was now she has less enemies than
she did before
you weren't gone long
no and and I have fewer enemies today
than I did yesterday
you don't show how you fit about that no
I'm not she didn't tell him anything too
specific about who she had killed on the
battlefield so I'm also interested in
knowing how John may feel about Daenerys
burning his best friend's family members
and another reason this relationship can
cause problems is because John and
Daenerys decided to take things one step
further by having sex and there is a
very good chance Daenerys is pregnant by
John this will add a whole new set of
problems in the north Littlefinger tried
to warn Shawn's about John being single
and Daenerys being single and beautiful
he tried to tell Sansa that they may
make an alliance together by getting
married but they spoke about this in
private and there is no reason to
believe anyone else in the north knows
about these suspicions yet so the big
question is how will everyone react when
and if they find out John and Daenerys
have been sleeping together they will
probably see this as John sleeping with
the enemy it will be very similar to
when John was in the Nights Watch and he
slept with eager who was a wildling the
Nights Watch is public enemy number one
it's not like John and Daenerys don't
already have things to worry about what
the army of the Dead and dealing with
Cersei and Euron but now they might have
to worry about fighting their own people
well mostly John because the North
already spoke out about John wanting to
meet her now they're gonna be blindsided
with the fact that John bent the knee
and took her to bed let's take a look at
another one of these clips from the
interview about this relationship here
are a few words from Isaac who plays
bran Stark what's gonna be interesting
is for bran it's like what am I gonna do
with this cuz just as everything was
coming together everyone was gonna join
together to fight inevitably Game of
Thrones will tear us apart
it seems as if Isaac has the same
feelings as Peter Dinklage something is
gonna happen next season that will cause
John and Daenerys to break off the
relationship this actually just reminded
me of something I almost forgot to say
there is another factor we need to
consider
John is of course a Targaryen himself
and Daenerys has no idea John is the
rightful heir to the Seven Kingdoms
which is something she wants to
claimed for herself so we also have to
think about how Daenerys will react to
this news
well Daenerys then see John as someone
in her way of claiming what she believes
to be hers or would she accept the fact
that John is her family and the king and
continue to have the same feelings for
him as she does now you also have to
think about if John and Danny will even
want to continue their relationship once
they find out they are related
Daenerys might not have as big of a
problem with it because she used to
think she was gonna have to marry her
own brother although she never wanted to
but I could see her being a little bit
more comfortable with this then John
would be but who knows what I actually
think will happen is once John finds out
the Narus is pregnant he will want to
seal the alliance no matter what even if
they are related John has always said he
will never father a bastard and have the
kid lived the same kind of life that he
did so John would want to make sure his
child is legitimized however it won't
mean tensions won't be very high before
this happens there is one more clip from
this interview I want to show you this
is what kid Harrington had to say I
think they both know it's wrong I think
they both know it's gonna cause problems
but it's that thing when you suddenly
feel that deeply about someone and you
go through those events together it's
like a runaway train you can't stop it
he also knows them getting together is
not good and it will cause problems and
I think the biggest problem will be
John's Bannerman coming to terms with
accepting Daenerys as their queen and
you really can't blame them for being
like this considering what Danny's
father had done but I think they will
realize they have no choice but to
accept her at the end of the day as soon
as everyone sees the night King and the
army of the Dead they will probably be
willing to work with just about anyone
this is something John realized right
away
he had no love for the wildlings but he
knew if everyone was gonna survive then
they would have to work together in
order to even stand a chance against the
dead sadly I don't think they are going
to spend too much time on the whole Sam
and Danny beef
either somehow I can just see Sam
understanding why Danny had to do what
she did but if I try to base my opinion
off what the actor said in their
interviews then I have to think
something significant will happen when
Daenerys arrives in Winterfell knowing
what Game of Thrones does to
relationships I have to consider that
one of these characters could die but I
don't think it would be because of the
problems between them the logical reason
would be because of the night king and
his massive force when I decided I would
use this topic for my next video I made
a post on patreon letting everyone know
what to expect and I was curious what
some other people had to say about this
so I want to read a few things they had
to say about Jon and Daenerys this is
what Doug Beck said the shock of seeing
Dani and the dragon should wear off
fairly quickly to me Sam's reaction
could be the most emotional to see as
far as John being the lawful heir to the
throne I think John and Danny won't
brush that aside to be dealt with after
the battle what the night came question
how do you think Cersei and company
would react to the knowledge that John
is the true heir
I think Cersei would be surprised to
find this out but it wouldn't change her
stance at all it doesn't matter who the
rightful heir is Cersei isn't going
anywhere without a fight to the death
however this could change things with
the golden company this could cause a
shift in who they decide to align
themselves with but there has been no
evidence of the golden company actually
switching sides
tons of spoiler photos have come out
from the battle in the north and there
wasn't any sign of new uniforms being
involved but we shall see Richard said I
think there might be some initial
distractions but after everybody has to
face the dead and sees her own Drogo and
they might feel different plus most of
them are gonna die anyway if they want
to fuss with her she could burn them up
just like the tarly's yeah you're
actually right Richard this is how I
always felt once they see the army of
the dead they're gonna be glad Daenerys
is there to help with her dragons and
large foreign army they also need to
understand what Daenerys has already
sacrificed to help John if the north has
any love for John who is their king then
they should respect the fact that
Daenerys
went beyond the wall and put her own
life in danger to save John which
ultimately led to the death of one of
her greatest weapons a dragon they might
try and spin it - and say the night King
would have never gotten a dragon of his
own if Daenerys didn't come to Westeros
which is technically true but we all
know she did it for the right reasons
she only went because she wanted to save
Jon and Jorah Mormont she would have
never done that if Jon didn't go in the
first place because Danny did try to
tell Jon not to go but he said Daenerys
had no right to keep him from going and
the rest is history
Gabe says I don't see Sam being that
upset about his father's death seeing as
his dad did treat him like crap but he
could hold a grudge for his brother's
death
maybe when Jon wins the war against the
whites I think most of everyone's still
alive will see him and Dany as heroes
when Danny arrives in Winterfell with
the Dragons the people will see that
they have a living chance of winning the
war if anybody from Winterfell has an
issue I believe it would be saw ins ax
but at the same time Danny would have
saved and got Winterfell back I don't
see Arya having an issue seeing that
John is her favorite and she really
believes in him this is well said Gabe
and I have to agree I know some of this
is easier said than done but everyone in
the north will eventually have to come
and see that having Dany her dragons and
men is a good thing considering they
have to at least win two wars the night
King needs dealt with and Circe needs
dealt with they need all the help they
can get as soon as Brian tells everyone
the wall is down and a hundred thousand
dead soldiers are marching their way it
should start to change everyone's tune
real quick Murray Hill says I think D
and E will bypass any complexity and go
for shock and all Arya and Sansa have
become D and E zone generic version of
the book characters the same will happen
with John and Danny there should be some
major inner conflicts between the
characters especially when John is told
that Dany is his aunt and when Danny
finds out that she is not the true heir
of Westeros in the end John will decide
to keep this knowledge to himself and
simply focus on destroying the knight
Cain and it will be someone else who in
Danny and everyone else of John's real
identity after the war is over I think
you're right about John's identity
getting revealed after the war bran
probably won't want to drop that on
John's head when he knows what John is
about to be up against he doesn't need
any major distractions right now the
last thing John needs is for this news
to get out and cause problems right
before the night king shows up they
can't afford anyone walking out on them
an alliance between John and Daenerys
makes sense they would be difficult to
defeat if she is pregnant they should
get married since this isn't real life
the incest isn't that big of a deal but
I wouldn't recommend having any more
kids together since they do share some
of the same blood but that's just my
opinion anyways how do you all feel
about the relationship moving forward do
you think something will happen that
will cause them to end it or do you
think one of them will die how will the
north and John's family react to John
being with Daenerys well anyone try to
kill one of them
or abandon their cause and does anyone
think Sam will make a big deal out of
Daenerys burning his father and brother
personally I don't see Sam doing
anything at a character he might bring
it up and Daenerys may even apologize
for it but I don't see them spending too
much time on this not with everything
else they need to take care of but maybe
they will surprise me what did you make
of the actors comments during those
interviews are they trying to hype
things up by having us believe their
relationship is doomed
put all your thoughts and questions down
below thank you all so much for watching
the video I really appreciate that
and I also want to thank everyone for
supporting the channel on patreon you
have really been a big help over the
months and I'm very grateful for that
have a great day everyone I'll see you
in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]